you know i give feminists a hard time
sometimes on this channel but the truth
is i i feel sorry for them they're very
lonely people and they're generally
pretty unattractive and they smell like
cat urine um and i don't say any of that
as an insult oh
[ __ ] i'm coming from a place of real
sincere concern and i'm afraid they
might be
making their loneliness problem even
worse when i read things like this from
the website everyday feminism which is a
great website by the way check it every
day that's why they call it everyday
feminism it's an article titled 10
things every intersectional feminist
should ask on a first date and these are
questions that apparently the author
lara witt is her name interrogates her
dates with on the rare occasion that she
gets one
read it from the article it says quote
as a queer femme of color i keep close
relationships with people who go beyond
allyship their true accomplices in the
fight against white supremacy queer
phobia and misogyny if you're not going
to support marginalized folks then we
can't be friends let alone date the
personal is political beyond the lovely
cushioning happiness and support that we
receive from our platonic relationships
which are in all honesty soul feeding
and essential feminists also date uh i
mean sparingly they did but there are
questions we have to ask before we get
close to some the following list of
questions is applicable to all
relationships certainly not just
cisgender heterosexual ones so that's
her setup and and now what we're going
to do now i think we're going to go
through these questions
and i will answer them myself i'll find
out
if i'm cut out to date a feminist i mean
if i was single
and mentally ill and actually wanted to
date a feminist this will tell me if i
pass the test so here we go
first question do you believe that black
lives matter do i think that actual
black people matter yes i do not more or
less than any other type of person but
yeah they matter but if you're asking me
if i support the organization known as
black lives matter the answer is no and
not only no but i think it's a terrorist
organization and everybody involved in
it should be locked in federal prison or
else deported to jupiter
uh two what are your thoughts on gender
and sexual orientation
well i don't have many thoughts about it
i don't spend my days thinking about
gender and sexual orientation but since
you brought it up
i think gender is an arbitrary and
useless concept invented by left-wing
perverts in the mid-20th century in
order to smuggle their degeneracy into
the culture i think we don't need gender
because we have biological sex and it
accurately and completely describes the
binary system which is in fact a binary
system gender complicates and obfuscates
which is what it was meant to do of
course
three how do you work to dismantle
sexism and misogyny in your life um i
don't
at all i don't think that there's much
sexism or misogyny to dismantle in the
first place but if i do find it um i
don't care enough to do anything about
it i just don't care like on on rare
occasion you i encounter something and i
think
yeah that's a little sexist and i think
okay well who cares we don't care
there are more than enough people on
that particular witch hunt so if i
encounter sexism i don't need to
dismantle it because i'm like well
there's people coming down there's that
that pitchfork mob coming down the road
here they'll they'll do the dismantling
i'll just continue on my way my
assistance isn't needed so um anyway i
do nothing at all as far as i go
four what are your thoughts on sex work
uh my thoughts are that prostitutes
should be imprisoned and so should pimps
and sex traffickers just throw them all
in jail
five are you a supporter of the bds
movement
no i'm not choose rule i should probably
simplify this and just tell you that i'm
not a supporter of any movement that you
support in fact if i did support a
movement and then you supported it too i
would stop supporting it just because
you're there like if i was at an
anti-cannibalism march
and then you showed up and said yeah i'm
anti-cannibalism too i would become
pro-cannibalism in that moment despite
you eat me
what is your understanding of settler
colonialism and indigenous rights my
understanding is that the western
conquest of the new world was a great
thing i'm extremely grateful for it i'm
very happy to live in our civilization
rather than the primitive civilization
it's supplanted i prefer this one i'm
glad that it's here i also know that you
feel the same way no matter what you
claim like you prefer to live here in in
western civilization
than in what came before it if you could
choose between this civilization
and a native american tribe you'd choose
this one conquest can be violent it can
be an ugly thing but it was also the way
of the world everywhere in the world for
all of history all people engaged in it
indigenous people did too in fact they
were often the most violent and brutal
conquerors of all
seven do you think capitalism is
exploitative
that's a stupid question number one does
it involve exploitation sure yeah i mean
to exploit something is to make use of
it for your own benefit capitalism
affords you the opportunity to exploit
your skills and your talents to make
money so yes you're exploiting of course
as a feminist you don't have any of
those skills or talents so you'll have
to just take my word for it i suppose
does capitalism involve sometimes or
enable
bad exploitation like dehumanizing
exploitation
sure of course it does it's a human
system it's not perfect no human system
is there's quite a bit less exploitation
in capitalism than there is to say
socialism where people all people are
totally subject to the exploitative
power of government eight can any human
be illegal um they can and they should
be deported if they are or they could go
to jupiter too i guess
nine do you support muslim americans and
non-muslim people from islamic countries
support them in what way like what do
you mean like buy them bras or something
she's got huge
tracts of land the question has no
meaning what do you mean support a whole
group of how could i support an entire
group what do you mean how do i do that
i mean don't tell me because i don't
care um ten does your ally ship include
disabled folks
no because i don't have any ally ship
i'd rather
jump out of a tenth story window than
ever be accused of engaging an allyship
also by the way stop trying to rope
disabled people into your identity
politics mess that's not fair to them
you can't wrangle them into the alphabet
mob just because they're a minority
group i mean if i ever get into a car
accident and i end up crippled i don't
want you to show up to the hospital and
wheel me over to your club okay you're
with us now no leave me alone you freak
how dare you speak to me and that's the
end of her list of questions and those
are my answers and by now my feminist
state will have long since run screaming
from the table or else collapsed into
tears on the floor i'm ready to go which
is really how a lot of my dates ended as
a single man and i doubt that i'll be
hearing from them again
which will probably be better for the
both of us i am aware of the effect i
have on women well whether you're a
feminist or not or want to go to date
with me or not well that doesn't matter
if you do or not because i am taken
ladies and i know you're upset by that
after everything you just heard make
sure you like and subscribe so you can
see more of this comment like right now
do it now